Oh Morty the ice cream corporation let
me tell you that they are in need of
slogans you should have heard their last
slogan what was it it was ice cream come
and taste it slips down your throat.
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my Rick and Morty gravity
falls Easter Eggs video there are a lot
of Easter eggs for gravity falls inside
Rick and Morty episodes in backgrounds
and because it's so amazing there's even
some Rick and Morty that showed up
inside gravity falls so we'll break it
all down if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the easter
egg videos and really important i'll
talk about at the end of the video but
Adult Swim and Toro made a Rick and
Morty car that they let me borrow for a
little while so I'll talk about that at
the end of the video there's a little
under 20 of these well try to get to
this as fast as possible
we'll start with season one and work our
way through season two three and then up to four so starting with season 1
episode 10 this is the evil Morty debut
on the series when they're on the run
from the Citadel of Rick's and they're
chasing each other through successive
portals to different realities they jump
into a dr. Seuss reality Rick opens a
bunch of portals to confuse them but if
you look here the camera lingers on it
for a little while there's a mug with a
question mark on it a pen and a notepad
that come out of one of the portals
there's a scene at the end of the
gravity falls episode Society of the
blind eye at the episodes ending there's
a credits gag where Stan loses those
three exact things into a giant portal
all right getting closer
every day it's getting strong yeah I
don't care if it's dangerous I don't
care how long it takes I'm going to pull
this off and no one's going to get in my
way a lot of people have tried to
connect gravity falls as being just an
alternate reality within the Rick and
Morty multiverse at the end of that same
episode when they're going home Rick is
referencing evil Morty and how cocky
Morty's are a very dangerous thing you
see Morty carrying a stack of books one
of them looks just like Journal three
then in season 2 episode 7 there's a
picture of gravity falls Bills cipher
that can be seen on a monitor while Beth
and Jerry are going to counseling most
of the time within Rick and Morty
episodes the gravity falls Easter eggs
are either bill cipher or something
referencing one of the journals right
before season 3 started in real life
Adult Swim did this weird promotion on
Instagram called the rick's diverse
which was released to promote the season  3 April Fool's Day episode everybody
remembers the April Fool's Day episode
click on the tag and then you could war
to all sorts of different planets and
dimensions when you go inside the
federal prison there's a room inside
with a visible monitor in the image of
bill cipher shows up with a symbol of
Journal 3 one picture below it you can
also see a collection of Rick's items in
a tray next to one is labeled a bunch of
question marks and contains three items
that grunkle Stan lost through his
portal in the episode Society of the
blind eye which is the Easter Egg that I
just referenced a second ago so we think
we can assume that Rick got his hands on
the items after the episode and just
happened to have them on his person when
he was thrown into prison at the end of
season 2 then in real life around this
time the gravity falls people and Disney
released a physical version of Journal 3
that you could buy the contained a plumb
bus as I journey on then in another page
there's a copy of Ford's wanted poster
with an encoded message on the corner
reading Rick was here as in Rick Sanchez
on the secondary page Ford also mentions
fist fighting with a talking chair which
may or may not be a reference to the
furniture universe with the talking
furniture within an actual gravity falls
episode - you see dipper looking through
journal 3 and he comes upon something
called a dream hipster monster that
looks exactly like scary Terry from Rick
and
with his kitchen utensils forefinger
blades instead of regular knives like
Freddy Krueger Nightmare on Elm Street
then during season 3 episode 1 in the
episode when Morty and summer get taken
to the Citadel of Rick's before the
council in the background you can see a
Mabel and dipper morty with him holding
journal 3 then in episode 5 world leader
lee conspiracy at the end of the episode
there's a tag scene with those little
aliens that escaped from the machine
without knowing it Beth had let them go
and they're just lounging by the stream
if you look in the background before
they get carried off by one of the hawks
you actually see bill cipher graffiti on
the bridge then in episode 6 a lot of
people noticed that toxic Rick's tuning
tower was actually really close to
Oregon which is where gravity falls is
when you're actually inside the toxic
environment with toxic rick and toxic
morty you look you see it decaying
eight-ball that's actually one of Bill
ciphers allies from weirdmageddon little
Easter eggs like that especially stuff
that shows up in the background and
there's really hard to spot is usually
something that the animators add
themselves sometimes dan and Justin have
no idea of the Easter eggs that get
included but there are animators that
also worked on gravity falls that then
work on Rick and Morty so it explains
how a lot of that stuff winds up in the
actual episodes without most people
knowing about it during episode 7 the
Rick lantus mix-up tales of the Citadel
you actually see that giant crowd shot
there's a Stanford Pines Rick in that
opening scene when they're all walking
through the street together during that
next episode episode 8 there's a whole
bunch when they're running through the
MC Escher dream palace with the truth
tortoise they run by a statue that looks
a lot like bill cipher when they go into
the room in the basement with all the
archives of their experiences and
memories there's a memory vial with
Stanford written on it as in Stanford
Pines from gravity falls implied that
there are memories from gravity falls
that Morty has as if he's traveled there
there's another vial in that very same
scene that says bill C as in bill cipher
so it's almost as if Rick and Morty have
also encountered bill cipher and their
adventures during the scene where Morty
inadvertently causes the horrific death
of zik-zak he's actually an omae's
winner a person in real life too just
won a contest and got to voice that
alien he hands him a business card when
he meets him for the first time and on
the back there's a design that looks
exactly like blueprints of the gravity
falls enter 2
national portals even though the portals
work the same way on gravity falls in
Rick and Morty the portals themselves
looked very different during episode 9
they have a concept called fruit peel
and that Rick creates to just keep Beth
busy so that she won't go around
terrorizing the neighborhood because she
was so scary as a child it's almost
exactly like the concept of Mabel's
Fantasyland created by bill cipher to
keep her busy because she was so
dangerous in a threat to his takeover of
gravity falls in the world later in the
episode when Rick is talking to Beth
about all the crazy things that she made
him invent he pulls out a police badge
the badge is a police badge from gravity
falls implying the Beth also visited
gravity falls when she was a little girl
a teaser shaped like a ladybug a fake
police badge a pink sentient switchblade
if you didn't see it there was obviously
the bonus episode done by tiara why
where you see Stanford Pines eating ice
cream with the version of Rick Sanchez
there's also some bill cipher graffiti
during that too between season 3 and
season 4 because Justin roiland and Alex
Hirsch creator of gravity falls are
friends in real life they did a charity
event together for h3h3 where they did
the voices for Rick Sanchez and together
this is a probably about as close as
we'll get to an actual big crossover
happening in real life then the only
reference that I could find during
season 4 so far is season 4 episode 4
last week's episode when Rick is using
the magician's portals he makes fun of
him who writes on portals well if you
look at the gravity falls portals all of
Stanford Pines portals have riding all
over them if you spotted any other big
gravity falls easter eggs during Rick
and Morty episodes or Rick and Morty
stuff during gravity falls episodes that
I didn't mention during the video just
write it below and
the comments many thanks to the turo
people for letting me drive the morning
mobile if you guys are familiar with the
concept of the Rick Mobile Adult Swim
created a car based on Rick Sanchez to
drive around and sell merch now they
partnered with Toro the world's largest
car sharing service to create a car
based on Morty's so they let me drive it
around for a little while the difference
between them and a traditional car
rental agency is that they're
peer-to-peer so you're actually
borrowing other people's really badass
cars you can also sign up to list your
car on the service and earn extra money
when people borrow it they're in about
fifty five hundred different cities in
the US the UK in Germany so ones are
pretty good the service is where you
live they're taking the more t-mobile to
a bunch of different cities in the US
right now I believe it's headed to San
Francisco next so if you do want to
drive more tea around for a little while
there's a chance that you could do that
there about 30% cheaper than traditional
rental car companies on average they
gave me a discount code to give you guys
that I'll add in the description it's
awesome 15 is $15 off on your first trip
but the price usually just depends on
what kind of car you want to borrow like
you could find a Tesla Model S you can
find Porsches so many thanks to the turo
people for letting me borrow the morning
mobile for a little while my full
episode 5 Easter Egg video will post on
Monday just like normal but if they're
any big bonus videos you want to request
just let me know in the comments
everyone click here for the brand-new
season 4 episode 5 trailer and click
here for my brand-new mandalorian
episode 6 video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight!